- [Mark] All right. Brandon.
Where did you grow up? Where are you from?
- I grew up in Los Angeles, California.
I was born in 1988, January 16th.
I'm a native from LA, I've
lived here all of my life.
- [Mark] Okay. And tell
me about your childhood.
You had both your parents growing up?
- No, I didn't have both of my parents.
I kinda had like, a village
of basically of women,
women basically.
My grandmother,
my mom
and my aunt who passed away from cancer.
Sorry, whats the other questions?
- [Mark] No. And so, so you lost your mom?
- No, I lost my aunt from cancer
but my mom wasn't fully in my life.
She had me at 19, so she, you know
she was raised in church.
So then my mom had her pregnancy
and basically, I'm like her miracle baby.
I'm her only child.
- [Mark] Okay.
- So I kind of have the
choice if I wanted to live
with my grandmother, but
I didn't have a choice
because my mother wasn't
always stable because she tried
but it was always a fight,
like, okay, this is my child.
When it came to my, my aunt, Shirley
my own grandmother and my mom.
So they kind of, all three
of those women spoiled me
and made this monster out of me.
- [Mark] So what, tell
me about your childhood.
- My childhood,
childhood, was okay.
It wasn't the best.
Let's just say it was okay outside,
but then the inside it wasn't the best
because I never had my own room.
And that's something that a child in LA
in a suburban area would have.
I've always lived like in a, a good area,
I guess you can say in West LA
but I didn't have like,
okay, this is your room
because you know, I
didn't have both parents.
I didn't meet my dad until the age of 21,
22.
Because he was actually
sent to the to the Marines
because of the fact he was,
I guess, popular.
But I believe he might've
been a game banger.
- [Mark] Okay.
- So my, my grandmother, which
is his mom who I didn't know
sent him off to the Marines
and I didn't meet him until I was 21.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And what kind of
kid were you in high school?
- Say it again?
- [Mark] What kind of kid
were you in high school?
- I was pretty cool.
I was active.
I went to Hamilton high school.
I was in the dance program.
Did a little sports.
I was in a music Academy program.
It was a performing arts school.
Yeah. Performing arts school.
I was pretty popular
but I didn't always fit in
like ninth grade I didn't,
they always were talking
about the shape of my head.
I didn't have the best looks.
So I had to basically, kind of compensate
and I was draining my aunt, my mom.
And she tried her best
because, you know,
she's a single parent and she's
kind of had a life like me.
Like she's always pushed
but she was pushed, you know back
trying to do other things.
And sometimes that's life, but
that's neither here or there.
- [Mark] Any crazy events
happened in high school?
- Oh, in high school, the
craziest event would be,
I guess me being
diagnosed with HIV, at 17.
- [Mark] How did that happen?
- I met a guy online
the summer,
right before going back to
school, in my senior year.
So I,
I went to a guy's house
who I was talking to
on the cell phone, you
know they had cell phones.
and,
basically I ended up meeting him,
the night of my best friend's party.
She turned 17.
It was in August.
I went to his house after.
I mean, I went to his
house after the party.
And after that,
we had sex,
which I have never had
anal intercourse, sorry,
with a guy before.
And he was a gang banger.
So that was kind of like
a rough kind of like,
Oh, that's a fantasy, I guess.
But I didn't think we were
gonna have sex like that.
So I kinda had no choice
because I was dropped off.
So me being under, you know, 17
it was like two in the morning.
I,
he was forceful basically.
And I can't say, oh, I was raped.
But it was like, okay, once it began
it just didn't end until he, finished.
And then we went to sleep
and he kicked me off.
I mean, he kicked me out in the morning.
Then I caught the bus, back home.
And then after that,
probably a month later
I was really sick.
I, my aunt went and got
me Kentucky fried chicken
and it was August.
And then yeah, September, end of September
I started getting really
sick, I believe so.
And the way it happened,
it was just really weird.
I thought I had the flu.
So I'm, I was losing so much
weight, losing all this blood.
And then to kind of fast forward
homecoming comes homecoming,
you know, homecoming
the dancing and all that.
Expected I would always show
up, you know fashionably,
fashionably, late but then
went to see what I had on
I couldn't fit any clothing.
I was sick.
I could barely make it there.
I, probably two weeks after that
school is starting,
well school had started
which was in October.
And I want Saturday morning,
well before that,
I actually was diagnosed.
They do three tests.
There's two weeks prior,
before going to the hospital.
I,
basically, you know, go to
the pediatrician, you know
you have the pediatrician, is
to the age of 18, at Kaiser.
My doctor asked me, he was
like, have you, are you
have you been sexually active?
I'm thinking, okay, have you followed me?
Because I wasn't sexually active really.
You know, as far as intercourse and he,
they took a test and
then I took another test
but then I came back
again, he took a test.
He said, I think you may be HIV positive.
And I'm like, what?
So he said, well, we're
gonna take another test.
So the last, the time after that
I brought my grandmother
and my mom with me.
I left them in the lobby
because I didn't know
what I was gonna find out.
And I was really sick
and still losing weight.
And then they told me,
the, my doctor told me.
And then I said, okay, what should I do?
Should I tell my mom?
And I was kind of crying.
He said, I'll go out to the lobby with you
and my mom.
She was already dramatic.
She, my grandmother was there too.
And of course, because,
something like that
my grandmother always
like, she can take care
of everyone when they're sick.
So,
I basically,
once at the lobby
and the doctor went
with me and told my mom
and my mom was on the ground crying
because,
I'm her only child.
And on top of that,
she probably felt like
she failed as a parent
because ,
my grandmother was so hard on her.
And it was like, okay,
I had to keep my grandmother happy
because I'm gonna get all
of these material things
from my aunt.
And my mom didn't feel like, okay.
I always felt like my
mom wasn't good enough
because she didn't give me what I want.
And I know people make mistakes.
And my mom tried her hardest.
And
(breaths heavily)
my mom, am sorry.
she heard that her child was HIV positive.
(breaths heavily)
and,
(sobs uncontrollably)
and she probably felt like,
okay I've failed as a parent.
And me now really know, okay,
I've wasted the,
education, being HIV positive
I just know I was gonna die.
They had us talk, on that same day.
They had us talk to,
It was like an outer body experience
where I was just like numb.
They had the doctor talk.
Yeah, we, we met all the, like,
we've got the
I guess the person who, sorry
we met the psychiatrist on that day.
Then we met another doctor.
And then we met another doctor, which I,
they, began to become my family
because like they kept you know,
they took me in because I'm young and,
And I couldn't, and I'm kind of sad
because I wanted to
still keep going there.
But I couldn't because of the fact
that I didn't have the proper insurance.
So I, you know, Kaiser kicked
me out and then I, you know
went to where everyone else goes.
And that was the best place for me.
But to revert back, two weeks later
I'm still losing all of
I'm in high school, I'm
still losing all this blood.
And it was just like, Oh my God,
I couldn't basically stand.
So,
I was missing school.
Who wants to miss, you
know, your senior year?
That's the year that
you can do everything.
I barely even, I don't
even think I did my dance.
So I did the dance show
because every year it would be a day I was
in the dance program.
But I barely was able to do it.
I was so sick.
That two weeks my best
friend was going to Atlanta
and my mom happened to see her.
And she was crying.
My mom was crying that morning.
It was a Saturday morning.
I fainted.
And my, my aunt
and my grandmother,
because you know, there
I went to school was closer.
And of course my mom
still trying her hardest.
Saturday.
I'm sorry that Saturday, I passed out
and I pass out a puddle of blood.
And after that,
- [Mark] Where were you bleeding from?
- I had infections.
They said I had ulcers
and I guess my immune system was so low.
I guess my body was
just prone to infections
and then I started just,
losing all of this blood.
- [Mark] Where losing blood?
- I,
- [Mark] Where?
- I was throwing up both
ways in and out, you know?
- [Mark] Okay.
- And in the, when the
blood became a certain color
it's like, okay, I don't
know what I should do.
So that's why I had no choice
but to go be rushed to the hospital,
they came and got me.
I,
went to Kaiser.
And I was in the hospital
for a whole month basically.
I had 13 blood transfusions,
and,
I guess it got better.
- [Mark] You're still here.
- Yeah. I'm 30 now.
I was diagnosed 2005.
Yeah 2005.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- High school.
And I'm here now.
So,
yeah.
(siren wailing)
That was the main event, but I graduated.
- [Mark] You made a lot of advancements.
- Yeah.
(laughs)
Yeah.
- [Mark] So you feel
lucky to be alive, right?
- Huh?
- [Mark] You must feel lucky to be alive.
- That'd be the lucky.
I feel like,
(train horns)
I feel like, it's kind
of part of my life now.
So I was like, okay.
Yeah. And you still have to
take medication, you know
you go in and out of things
and then things happen.
And am here.
- [Mark] So what, what are you
doing today with your life?
- What am I doing now?
- [Mark] Yeah. Where do you live?
- I'm homeless.
- [Mark] You're homeless.
You're here on Skid Row?
- I guess everywhere downtown
is almost considered Skid Row
but I, yeah, I come
and eat at the mission.
- [Mark] You live in a tent?
- No, I'm more of a train sleeper.
I like to be on the train.
I don't feel safe down here.
I get bullied.
Yeah. I don't really fit in down here.
- [Mark] So you're riding train all night?
- Yeah.
Yeah.
Which that is good that they
actually keep the train running
for homeless people.
But yeah, I, I came back out here
because of the fact that I lost my place
and I was so happy to have a place.
Cause you know, a lot I've
happened after losing my aunt
but that's neither here or there.
But I'm homeless and
I don't live in a tent.
I don't really like tents.
I like to be in doors with, you know
walls and the door and all that.
And I don't wanna get
too complacent with that.
But,
- [Mark] And do you use any
drugs that are on the street?
- Yeah,
I do.
- [Mark] Which ones?
- The popular crystal meth.
- [Mark] Crystal meth is popular I know.
- Yeah,
I do.
But I guess you could say
I was doing that before.
It didn't have anything to do
with me actually coming back
to Skid row.
But I've been doing crystal meth
because I consider myself,
not gay,
but I, I have intercourse with males.
So that was, you know, that
was a gay drug at first
and then it hit here and
now it's really an epidemic
but yeah, I am currently
doing crystal meth.
- [Mark] And what, do you have any plans?
I mean what, you're kind
of stuck here in Skid row
doing drugs and it's like,
it's got that the most.
- Plans, well my plan fell through.
I had a place.
And it's almost, it hasn't
even been a year yet
but I ain't got a place DMH
and I have to relinquish my unit
because I was being bullied.
I'm being bullied again.
(laughs)
So I'm used to being bullied
because right before coming to the Roslyn
or what have you, the DMH.
I was at a transitional home.
I was bullied there by all the men.
I mean, they were taking my clothes.
I mean, I was calling my
mom every day, saying there,
this, this is happening, that's happening.
And I was just always,
everywhere that I go
I'm always kind of by
myself, even if I'm popular
but people won't like me for no reason.
So I think I'm just, I'm
expected for that set.
I expect that to happen now
but it's really gotten physical.
Like me getting hit.
I got hit.
I've been hit on a train, for no reason.
I've had a knife put out
on me, for no reason.
I'm asleep, I wake up
and a guy has a knife
because he's tweaking.
I am,
no actually he suck me in my eye
and you know you're asleep.
Who?
That's almost like, okay,
did I get sucked out of life?
It feels weird.
I didn't know what happened.
Then he had a weapon
which was a knife ,out of
I don't know why I'm the only,
It seems like I'm the only one downtown
that gets bullied as much.
Yeah.
I can be with other people
and they won't say anything
to them, but they will
say something to me.
But I guess it's, that's what happens.
So I'm here now and it's not that bad.
It's this Turner.
I mean, this come around
well I guess this,
second time being homeless.
I don't, I find clothes
and things like that.
I've always been into
clothes and things but,
it's not that bad now I
know how to handle it.
And, I have these puppies,
puppies on a leash now, so yeah.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I'm good.
- [Mark] All right.
Well Brandon, thank you.
- [Brandon] Thank you.
- [Mark] For sharing your story
and good luck with
wherever you go from here.
- [Brandon] Thank you.
- [Mark] All right. Thank you.
- [Brandon] All right.